[Music]  well that's it  confirmation of the result the  Conservatives have formally won this  general election taking their three  hundred and twenty sixth seats meaning  they cannot be beaten whatever happens  now I think taking their 327 as well  seeing her Dagenham and Raynham John  Kronus big Beast the Labour Party  they're going conservatives gaining that  the s there it goes up to 327 the  Conservatives and Boris Johnson have won  the general election of the winter of  2019 well a formal moment Beth I mean  you as we were counting that down there  that intake of breath on John Curtis for  John Rogers in Dagenham I had heard that  that was quite tight on the ground but  I'd also heard that Labour were hopeful  of holding it one of very big interest  to John Becker but